guten tag schön sind sie auch ein nein
ja bei uns und wir beginnen heute bei
adam und eva tatsächlich wir wollen
nämlich klären warum frauen bis heute um
gleichberechtigung kämpfen müssen
seit wann das machtgefälle zwischen
männern und frauen überhaupt besteht und
ob dann wirklich eva schuld ist
bei der klärung dieser fragen helfen mir
der evolutionsbiologe carel van schaik
und die feministische theologin
christine stark schön dass sie beide
hier sind herzlich willkommen
carel van schaik sie haben kürzlich
dieses buch hier geschrieben zusammen
mit dem historiker kai michel und darin
beschreiben sie wie die
gleichberechtigung und die soziale
ungleichheit zwischen männer und frauen
eben eine anomalie der menschheit sei
denn über die größte zeit haben die
menschen gleichberechtigt nebeneinander
gelebt ich frage sie ist also das papier
hat bald am ende
es ist eine anomalie ob es am ende ist
liegt an uns natürlich in der schweiz
ist es gesetzlich natürlich eigentlich
von am ende für für den gesetzen männer
und frauen gleich aber es gibt wirklich
verborgene verdeckte
diskriminierungsfälle die man so zb in
der medizin ist es so dass viele
krankheitssymptome sind für männer
beschrieben und wenn man dann frauen mit
dem gleichen mit der gleichen krankheit
hat dann haben sie oft andere symptome
und vielleicht kriegen sie dann nicht
die richtige behandlung medikamente
werden häufig nur an männern getestet
natürlich haben frauen das problem mit
diesen zyklen und so weiter und dann ist
es ist sind die daten wie adresse sie zu
analysieren genau aber dann geht etwas
vergessen also es gibt ein ganzes buch
über dieses thema unsichtbare frauen
also dass es ist eben daran denkt man
nicht man denkt es ja ja alles schon
vorbei aber da gibt es immer noch so
verdeckte diskriminierung seit sie
sprechen da auch diesen gender pay gap
am freistaat diese these war in die
schon bekannt war dass erstaunlich für
sie also zugegeben war vieles in dem
buch
für mich weniger erstaunlich weil ich
schon kannte mich natürlich auch gerade
mit den theologischen teilen schon
beschäftigt hatte im eigenen studium
einem eigenen theologischen denkens
neu sind natürlich also alle
erkenntnisse die irgendwie dann in diese
sie sprechen ja von 99 prozent der
menschheit zeit und irgendwie es mir das
eine prozent sehr vertraut und in den
life eingeschrieben
und vieles was ich von der vorzeit darin
gelesen habe ich auch neu gelernt das
fand ich auch interessant das wollen wir
dann heute auch erörtern
ich möchte das aber erklären weshalb sie
hier drin sie sprechen über nicht vom
patriarchat sondern von der patricks
sprechen ja weshalb machen sie das er
dass das hat auch historische gründe das
patriarchat es ist häufig wird das
anders verwendet aus dass in der
eigentlich in der anthropologie
technisch gemeint ist das ist einfach
eine gesellschaftsstruktur wo die männer
dominieren alle wichtige ämter haben zum
beispiel alle vererbte ämter usw
und dann was wir auch zeigen wollen mit
patricks das ist ein spiel auf matrix
dieser film dass das ist eine art von
weltanschauung wobei die männer seite
das normale ist und das andere eine art
abweichung hier darstellt und eine
verzerrung könnte man sagen und gerade
das das dass das beispiel mit der
medizin sieht man dass das es ganz tief
in uns in uns eingreift und und unser
unsere unsere weltanschauung wirklich
geprägt hat was sagen sie denn als
feministische theologin dazu ist das ein
mehrwert diese dieser neuschaffung des
begriffs paar tricks mit anspielung auf
matrix ja mit anspiel auf dem matrix bin
ich mir nicht sicher
weil also das wäre jetzt ein
filmgespräch wenn wir uns über matrix
unterhalten weil es da ja eine
scheinwelt ist und der film eben auch
sehr männlich ist also ich mag ihn als
unterhaltungsfilm aber er ist schon sehr
sehr männlich aber auch serie also mit
ganz viel religiöser
symbolik durch drängt deswegen also es
war spiel ist schön weil es bisschen
einen löst von anderen dingen aber es
wäre noch schöner wenn man noch ein
weniger belastet das wort als matrix
finden würde also matrix durch den durch
den feldern belastet aber es ist es ist
anregend mannschaft auch beim bild war
er genau aber um das noch mal mit dem
patriarchates sack heißt ja auch die
herrschaft weniger männer über mehrere
menschen das ist das missverständnis
gesagt alle männer herrschen alle
beherrschten sinnlos sondern das quasi
die herrschaftsform von männlich
definierten herrschaft regiert es kann
ja auch frauen seien über eine mehrheit
der beherrscht und würden sie sagen dass
herrscht dennoch heute das patriarchat
wie sie es gerade beschrieben haben ja
das patriarchat das klingt zu wirken wie
eine instanz ja dieses wird oder nicht
ein lebewesen aber als struktur würde
ich das schon sagen in verschiedenen
abstufungen sicher sind wir hier in so
einem in seiner kleinen welt überhaupt
den west mitteleuropa also in der
schweiz oder aber auch in anderen
ländern wo wir uns mit problemen
herumschlagen die ich als partei
bezeichnen würde
die für andere gesellschaften schon
enormer schritt wären also wenn ich mich
über drei wochen vaterschaftsurlaub oder
so denkt na ja also und alle denken ist
es also viele denken es ist eine
errungenschaft einige oder viele sagen
es ist naja dann gibt es aber auch
länder wo es gar keine keinen
gesellschaftlichen schutz gebert für
werden der eltern oder gewordene eltern
deshalb setzen wir damit auch ein
zeichen wenn wir in der schweiz zeigen
dass eine gesellschaft wo das
patriarchat oder die patricks nicht mehr
so prominent vorhanden ist dass man
trotzdem ein ganz glückliches wohl
fahrendes land produzieren kann
das ist ein zeichen für andere leute auf
der welt für andere frauen auf der welt
aufsteigen wir doch mal richtig ein sie
beginnen in ihrem buch mit beider
paradies geschichte sind im jetzt schon
zum zweiten mal die bibel als ob ihr als
forschungsobjekt als evolutionsbiologie
erklären sie mir weshalb sie das machen
weshalb ist das ihr forschungsobjekt
weil die die schöpfungsgeschichte
bericht 1
und übrig zwei natürlich bei vielen
menschen noch sehr prominenz eine rolle
spielt also in unserer gesellschaft ob
man jetzt gläubig ist oder nicht an
diese geschichte kommt nicht herum und
es wird ja immer auch noch aus
rechtfertigung verwendet um zu sagen die
frauen sind bürger zweiter klasse
wenn sie ansprechen dass das jemand noch
vorhanden sind das stelle ich auch fest
virulent vorhanden nämlich zb in
werbungen man sieht hier es geht um die
verführung david eva longoria die
schauspielerin dafür benutzt oder jeden
wo es um einen verführerischen duft
gehen sollte
das finde ich ja schon erstaunlich wie
das vorträgt obwohl meines längstens
schon auch als mythos ja sag mal
entlarvt hat er ist einfach ein sehr
schöner mütter sondern sehr also sehr
einprägsam oder wir haben in der die ich
sagen würde fehlerhaften auslegung
dieses zweiten schöpfungsbericht haben
wir sehr einfache rollen oder es ist
klar wer gut und böse ist und mann und
frau es ist ein es ist ja irgendwie
peinlich als fehlerhaft ist das finde
ich interessant dass sie das so
formuliert die auslegung die ich mir
aber was ich erst mal sagen weil es das
ist wie ein märchen ist also ein
begrenzte personenzahl oder wien
tragödie griechische drama macht
irgendwas und daraus leitet sich was ab
und das ja es hält sich hartnäckig
fehlerhaft hab ich jetzt gemeint aber da
sollte man dann ins detail gehen ist
diese das ist geschlechterstereotypen
fest schreibt also ich finde ja diese
werbung weniger es ist eine andere bühne
figur von dem verfügen aber hier
natürlich also die ist sexistisch würde
man sagen oder sie spielt mit dem
sexismus also die frage ist ob ich jetzt
aus feministischer empörung dieses nicht
heißen soll
oder erst recht quasi aus das liegt
nicht an der wir haben mit mitnehmen da
bin ich frei genug zu sagen es mir
schmeckt oder nicht aber der fehler ist
gewissermaßen das dass mit dieser
führung verbunden wird ist das habe ich
jetzt noch niemand genau also verführung
lesen wir ja auch gleich als also sehr
sexualisiert ausgeliehen
die christliche auslegungs geschichte
dann hat man schon sagen es ist wirklich
die christliche geschichte die da eine
brille darauf gelegt hat und das hat
sich dann auch noch mal verstärkt also
nicht also im neuen testament ist darauf
gelegt worden und dann hat sich nochmal
verstärkt diese sexismus er in der würde
ich sagen in der bibel nicht gegeben ist
bester beweis ist dass wir diese ganze
sexistische auslegung im judentum nicht
haben ja die teilen diese geschichte und
haben sie auch schon quasi also ist die
den christen vorausgehende religion also
die es gibt schon eine lange tradition
je nach entstehungszeit 800 jahre
funktioniert die geschichte ohne die
diesen sexismus und dann schlägt der
rhein und das meine ich mit der falschen
lesen und das ist ja auch sehr
erstaunlich weil die die eva eigentlich
in der geschichte eine ziemlich starke
rolle spielt ist autonom der man
gehorcht und das bringt mich auch zur
nächsten frage herr van schaik das buch
heißt die wahrheit über eva was denn die
lüge über eva genau diese idee dass das
wie man heutzutage diese diese zweite
schöpfungsbericht bedeutet nämlich dass
die frau dem mann untertan sein muss das
war ja nie der fall vorher und das ist
das ist diese anomalie das ist
irgendwann mal entstanden aber gleicher
zeit mit der schrift mit staat bildung
mit also weitergabe von von von
erkenntnisse usw
als wäre das die ganze
menschheitsgeschichte das natürlich
nicht so
es geht so weit wie sie vorhin gesagt
haben der mann also bei diesen medizin
buch der mann als das standard mensch
das haben wir das ist schon dagegen weil
wir ja die also das wort adam ist dann
auch in der bibel immer die bezeichnung
für der mensch also und dass das ist
schon wie angelegt also eva so der der
abweichende mensch oder der die andere
oder wie wir es auch in der familie
zwischen philosophie weiss ich ganz
interessant finde es natürlich dass sie
jetzt das buch als agnostiker lesen sie
schreiben dass selber in beiden büchern
im vorwort für sie ist die bibel kein
heiliges buch für sie jetzt auch als als
christin feministische theologin wie
gesagt hat dass ein anderer
stellenwert was verpassen wir denn wenn
wir die bibel mit diesem
anthropologischen blick lesen oder
verpassen wir überhaupt etwas ja das war
ich ihm nicht irgendwas verpasst also
ich lese es anders durch meine prägung
und durch meinen quasi meinen
persönlichen glauben und ich komme da
auch nicht raus das anders zu lesen das
finde ich immer interessant mit so
vergleichs texten sie bringen der
kritische texte man kann auch andere
texte oder euro kanonische texte bringen
ich möchte mich ließ die anders also es
ist für mich interessanter oder
relevanter die auseinandersetzung mit
biblischen texten also da bin ich
vielleicht auch protestanten einfach
genug dass es so der der anker ist und
an dem er sich dann auch abarbeiten muss
natürlich als auch zum mehrwert oder
weniger wert gibt wenn man es mit
anderen die frage dreht sich doch auch
darum inwiefern das ja auch göttlich
inspiriert ist was man liest oder ja gut
aber das ist das ist jetzt würde ich
jetzt auch sagen im vest
mitteleuropäische theologie auch nicht
der standard die an die annahme also
sicher nicht verbal inspiriert also die
vorstellung dass es quasi von gott
direkt in die person die es zum ersten
mal aufgeschrieben hat hindurch in die
feder gegangen ist ohne dass die person
auch mal darüber nachgedacht hat also
die vorstellung findet man natürlich in
publizistik oder oder von genitalen
kreisen aber die habe ich jetzt auch nie
so geht ja ja genau auf die frage war ja
wenn's göttlich inspirierter ist hat er
nicht automatisch dass es auch diktiert
ist dass es auch ein großer unterschied
oder ok also ich habe ja also ich würd
sagen es ist sich als die bibel gibt mir
geschichten oder texte die mir die um
andere menschen mir über gott erzählen
also ich bin ja eben diese göttliche
inspiration klingt so top down und ich
würde schon eher aus einer glaubens
haltung heraus sehen und dann muss ich
mich damit auseinander setzen und
schauen also prüfet alles das gute
behaltet steht auch in der bibel
also ich muss mich damit
auseinandersetzen welche texte in
welcher art und weise zu mir heute
sprechen oder über die ich sprechen
möchte kaum wir doch zu ihren
forschungsergebnissen haben uns zuvor
schon gesagt ein großteil der
menschheitsgeschichte hat man offenbar
egalitär in jeder jäger und sammler
gesellschaften gelebt nomadisch auch und
das war die normalität
jetzt habe ich hier stift und papier
dabei damit sie uns das auch so ein
bisschen visualisieren können was denn
dahinter menschlichen welt so innerhalb
weniger weniger jahr hundertausende so
schief gelaufen ja dann fangen wir mal
an bei ungefähr zwei millionen jahren
nicht und wenn wir heute also zwei
millionen jahren vor zwei millionen
jahren sind sie belege gut dass die
erste schimpansen artige menschenaffen
auf die savanne gegangen sind also die
savanne
was ist daran so spannend die savanne
ist ein sehr gefährliches kapitals und
es ist offen man kann nicht mehr auf die
bäume zurückfliegen
man muss sich also verteidigen das hat
man gemeinsam machen müssen denn alleine
ist man nicht gut genug
es hat auch die technologie natürlich
einen vorteil verschafft denn das hat
man mit stöcken und steinen gemacht aber
man muss doch danach überleben also
etwas essen
die futter heran schaffung dort ist
schwieriger aus dem wald es gibt viel
weniger sanfte früchte usw also dass
auch dass wir technologisch das bedeutet
also dass man hier eine art ökologische
nische reinrutscht so allmählich denn
das war natürlich nicht gewollt das war
weil die die wälder geschrumpft sind und
sie müssten raus ist eine klimatische
frage eine klima klimaänderung frage
also die entwickeln sich eine nische die
über die jahrhunderte tausende das jetzt
nennen wir das ich jagen und sammeln
das spannende ist also das eigentlich
die geschlechter daher mehr oder weniger
unterschiedliche nischen hatten und sich
alles teilen müssten
das hat sich natürlich in die
psychologie eingeprägt denn jede art hat
eine psychologie die dazu hört wie man
lebt und wie man es sein so genanntes
subsistenz bestreitet und das fehlt also
dazu dass wir eine art komplementarität
zwischen männern
frauen entwickelt haben dass innerhalb
der das muss ich auch sagen hier
entstehen also auch allmählich paar
bindungen
das sehen wir bei fast allen arten von
klima hat die in riesigen gruppen leben
dann bricht das monopol vom alpha
männchen weg und dann gibt es raum
könnte man sagen spielraum für paar
bildungen das sieht man sehr allgemein
und das hat sich dann bei menschen
durchgesetzt nie so wie heutzutage
darauf kommen dennoch zu sprechen da ja
genau das war natürlich noch nicht so
ganz so aber allmählich hat sich das
entwickelt und dann jetzt reden wir euch
das ist nicht mal richtig denn hier wäre
ungefähr eine million so ungefähr
vor 12.000 jahren die eiszeit die letzte
eiszeit geht zu ende
und diese nomadische jäger und sammler
wo er das muss ich noch sagen natürlich
die männer und frauen war mehr oder
weniger gleich richtig denn der mann
braucht was die frau gesammelt hat die
frau braucht was der mann gejagt hat und
das ist das teilen innerhalb der familie
zwischen den familien in einer so eine
kleine bande hand nennt man das auf
englisch wird geteilt und auch manchmal
zwischen diesen bands leute werden
wechseln und hund raus und manchmal
helfen sich noch gegenseitig wenn es
hier mal weniger zu essen gibt und so
starke komplementarität trage
komplementarität totale unterstützung
auch bei der kindererziehung also der
sogenannte corporate branding das wofür
es kein schönes deutsches wort das man
in gruppen die mit gruppen aufzucht das
klingt ganz schön aber das ist nicht
eine frau für ein kind genau und und und
dass die frau viel hilfe bekommt ja wenn
sie ihr kind erziehen möchte und also
das hat sich so das ist unsere erste
natur nennen die psychologie der mensch
das des menschen und der menschen hat
sich so über diese zwei millionen jahren
etablieren
dann ist die eiszeit zu ende wird
plötzlich an bestimmten orten zum
beispiel in diesem fruchtbaren halbmonds
insbesondere sollte ist das denkmal an
jericho diese diese westliche
jetzt plötzlich ganz nett viel wild
unmengen von von gräser wovon man die
samen essen kann die waren damals noch
ein bisschen kleiner als heutzutage das
ist dann heutzutage weizen und roggen
usw geworden und dann haben die leute
sich immer weniger bewegen bewegt
tschuldigung weil sie haben sich mehr
oder weniger angesiedelt diese leute
vorher waren immer normal ich aber wenn
das essen vor der tür wächst da muss man
nicht mehr was noch nicht mehr weggehen
das macht man gerne uns aus dieser
umwandlung hat sich dann über ein paar
tausend jahre die landwirtschaft erstmal
das würde man hat jetzt hakt nennen und
dann nach einer weile wird intensiver da
würde man jetzt über ackerbau und
viehzucht also da diese hat dieser
schnitt ist die sesshaftigkeit die
presse ist hier dieser sieg aber das hat
hier angefangen
je nachdem wo man sagt ab hier sind es
menschen ist natürlich beliebig früher
war es 200.000 jetzt reden wir von
300.000 am man könnte auch von 500.000
reden dann sehen wir die ersten hinweise
dass sie ganz komplizierte werkzeuge
machen wobei teile zusammengesetzt
werden je nachdem wie man sieht man dass
die größte zeit der
menschheitsgeschichte haben mir ganz
anders gelebt aus nach dieser sesshaft
genau das interessiert mich jetzt
nämlich dieser kleine teil man sieht es
ja schon da haben wir einen großen teil
die täter und sie haben sogar gesagt
eben das gegenseitige unterstützung und
jetzt geschieht etwas ganz interessant
dass ab der sesshaftwerdung da ist es
nämlich nicht mehr egalitär was ist was
geschieht da das lustige war die erste
paar tausend jahre dieses ethos ist so
tief verankert kann man nicht einfach
abschütteln wie wird man nicht los das
fängt erst an wenn die landwirtschaft
entsteht also bei diesen hack bauzeiten
da war eigentlich noch nichts neues
das ist das sogenannte mythische
matriarchat worauf wir vielleicht noch
zu sprechen kommen hier wird dann anders
wenn nämlich die überschüsse also die
produktion hoch geht und man vorräte hat
dann kriegt man hat man das problem dass
leute das vielleicht sich aneignen
wollen fremden muss man es verteidigen
und das ist der erste schritt richtung
pattaya hat das dann die männer die
müssen dort bleiben wo sie geboren sind
weil die clans müssen jetzt ihr gebiet
verteidigen ihre vorräte ihre häuser
ihre land irland das der erste schritt
zum patriarchat gut da sprechen wir
gerne jetzt gleich noch darüber es
musizierten zu verstehen es gibt so was
wie sesshaftigkeit die irgendwann
eintrifft nach dieser ganzen thema
savanne usw sesshaftigkeit dann ein paar
tausend jahre kann man die alten natur
quasi oder psychologie nicht abwerfen
und erst dann kommt sowas dann
irgendwann wie eine männliche
nominierung deshalb wissen wir das denn
so genau es gibt ja keine schriftlichen
zeugnisse von damals ja aber teilweise
haben wir zwei quellen teilweise sie
sehen wir viele von diesen stufen im
nachhinein gesehen auch noch
ethnographische also manchmal geht
irgendwo und sieht leute die sind auch
jäger sah man sieht leute die sind doch
haben noch einfacher hat baukultur mit
ganz tiefen dichten man sieht leute die
haben noch landwirtschaft aber nur mit
steinwerkzeugen usw
und natürlich das ist die eine seite und
die archäologie sie erzählt uns auch
immer mehr zum beispiel in diesem fall
können wir mit mid engine dna schauen
bekommen die leute her
die dort leben aber was sagt uns das
wissen hat können wir daraus die die
geschlechterverhältnisse ableiten habe
ich natürlich stehen wir noch nicht von
große ungleichheit hier sehen wir den
ersten schritt patri lokal lernen
bedeutet dass die männer alle zu hause
bleiben
das bedeutet aber schon auch dass die
frauen längst woanders herkommen
die sind nicht bei ihrer familie hier
war das alles ganz anders
denn das ist alles sehr flexibel und man
kann in fünf minuten bei der familie
sein und zum beispiel werden die unrecht
getan wird dann kannst du deine familie
ganz schnell rekrutieren um etwas daran
zu ändern und dann passiert es auch viel
weniger
natürlich und sie beschreiben das ja
auch ganz eindrücklich hier drin was da
alles geschieht naps dem dass es dass
die frauen eben weg gehen müssen und
dadurch ihre netzwerke quasi gestört
werden dass die geburtenraten steigen
das ist schon hier und die ernährung
sich verändert und die wird viel
einseitiger natürlich denn nach einer
weile das ist das problem
oder das geheimnis der landwirtschaft im
allgemeinen die dichten gegen hoch wenn
es keine solchen gibt mal die dichten
gehen über die zeit immer höhe wirklich
hunderttausendfach nach einer weile und
erstens kann man nicht mehr zurück und
zweiten blick gibt es dann diese diese
eigentlich ständige gefahr dass das
kriege gibt und und und und raubzüge und
so weiter das ist ja ganz interessant
jetzt in bezug auf das eigentum das sie
zuvor auch angesprochen haben das kennt
ja die bibel als geschichte auch wenn
man kein & aber denkt also nicht als die
dichte hochkommt ich habe gerade bei der
dichte gedacht dass das auch den den
aggressivitäts regel also ob die
männlichen vorfahren von uns einfach dem
dichte stress nicht standgehalten haben
bei kain und abel kennt man genau das
also die erste gewalttat quasi in der
bibel schließt sich ja gleich an dieses
kapitel an und das ist verbunden also
weil kein & aber jeweils der eine als
ackermann der andere als viehzüchter
dargestellt wird verdichtet sich so eine
konkurrenzsituation und es wird
natürlich logisch dargestellt als
konkurrenz in bezug auf gott aber es
endet mit dem brudermord es endet damit
dass der einem an dem anderen den
schädel einschlägt und das ist ja auch
so eine beschreibung die ich von ihnen
dann lese auf große gruppen bezogen also
dass die jäger also dichte stress oder
die jäger die sich auch langweilen habe
ich an manchen stellen das gefühl gehabt
wenn man keine tiere mehr jagen kann
jagt man seine gleichen ja aber bei kain
und abel geht es natürlich um brüder und
dass das ist eigentlich die der letzt
der nächste schritt wenn es dann mal
wirklich gute produktive landwirtschaft
gibt dann gibt es sachen die man
vererben kann
wer wird da er ein dass sie
die biologie jetzt via in der männlichen
linie kann man viel mehr enkelkinder
produzieren aus in der weiblichen linie
denn eine frau hat vielleicht fünf sind
20 kinder und ein mann kann und die
polygone entsteht dann auch jetzt werden
zb die söhne sind die einzigen erben
aber unter den zähnen ist meistens auch
so dass es die sogenannte primo garnitur
gibt dass der älteste sohn alles erbt
oder löwenanteil bekommt
und plötzlich werden diese brüder jetzt
konkurrenten und das war vorher
natürlich nie der fall war neben
passiert auch den rest die freude und
den kann man blind vertrauen und auch in
der verteidigung müssen sie sich blind
vertrauen im krieg und so weiter
hier plötzlich geht es geht es falsch
meine in der ganzen geschichte die
königssee die haben sich gegenseitig
immerhin lassen die an die gurgel
gegangen
das ist neu diese dieser dichte
geschichte ist natürlich eine andere
geschichte dass jetzt die männer konnten
am anfang haben wir einfach weiter
gejagt aber da gibt es nicht das wird
umso weniger das geht und dann hat man
gemerkt hätte ich kann die nachbarn
überfallen und dort ist erst mal statt
für eine frau zu bezahlen kann ich es ja
einfach und wenn das mal anfangen diese
spirale dann hört nie auf
mich wundert natürlich schon wenn sie
sagt man schöne frau bezahlen da steckt
auch schon ganz viel dahinter
sie haben aber zuvor noch etwas
spannendes gesagt sie haben da bei
diesen kleinen punkten gesagt das
mythische material das ist ja immer so
nah ist eine gängige tt man wieder
aufgekocht wurde auch im termin ist
unter anderem der 60er jahre und danach
noch hat man viel energie in die
erforschung des materials gesteckt
weshalb war das war ein renner
das ist richtig also wir selber deshalb
kann ich nicht beantworten es ist noch
interessant ist es in wien und eine
phase die auch wieder so ähnlich ist man
blickt in den paradiesischen gefahr
vergangenheit wo es ja genau umgekehrt
bei dem ja also es ist ja nicht
gleichberechtigung sondern hat einfach
die frauen ja die idee mehr gut
das ist sicher quasi auch eine
die umkehrung der verhältnisse
geschuldet also diese fantasie wobei
eine material fand er sie auch immer
sein kann das ist die bessere art der
herrschaft ist also dass es quasi nicht
die unterjochung also das quasi die
herrschenden weiblich sind ja also ich
sehe es ja auch als die fantasie an
aber das ist quasi anders aufgeladen ist
also material chartis positiver
aufgeladen als adressaten überraschung
jetzt genau in der ntt logi sagen wir
diese material und hug baugesellschaften
also es ist über die mutter die
erbschaft quasi über die mutter weiter
habe viel zu erben gibt es ja legendär
aber das land ist kommunal das jetzt in
der weiblichen linie ja und da sagen wir
das gegenteil von party 8 ist nicht
matriarchat sondern gleichheit das
konsensdemokratie sagen wir mal
und das ist es ist ganz spannend dass
mathe hat dieses konstrukt wo das
herkommt das hat natürlich viel mit
backofen zu tun neunzehnten jahrhundert
das war alles fantasie uns natürlich
gibt es diese auto berichte aber die
darf man nicht trauen denn das ist
häufig wird das gemacht um das
patriarchat groß und gut zu machen und
schauen mal wie primitiv die jetzt so
eine entwicklungsgeschichte dann genau
das finde ich interessant sie sagen das
ist fantasie aber trotzdem trotzdem weil
sie natürlich wird mächtig eben genau
mit mit mit backofen denn sie gerade
genannt haben ich möchte noch etwas kurz
erklären weil eine gängige vorstellung
oder ich sage mal ein gängiges vorurteil
ist doch das wenige das männer über
frauen herrschen aufgrund von physischer
überlegen
sie sagen aber weder muskelkraft noch
größere hat das ausgelöst und die hier
gerade als aufschließen
denn denn dann wäre sollte es doch immer
schon gewesen sein
die männer waren auch immer schon größer
und stärker und das war sogar hier noch
schlimmer
wir wissen natürlich nicht genau denn
dafür sind die fossilfunde zu zu wenig
und zu sagen wie genau der dem office
muss sich genommen hatten ja diese zeit
aber die männer waren immer größer als
die frauen und es aber das ist das
schöne jäger sammler literatur wenn man
sie liest alle betonen die gleichheit
niemand sagt der mann
der frau zwingen ja es gibt mal
vielleicht mal eine vergewaltigung hier
und da aber das läuft meistens schlecht
ab für den mann
also es ist nicht die stärke und das
sehen wir genauso bei unseren verwandten
also bonobos kennen viele leute
natürlich weil sie so lustig sind
da sehen wir auch demand die menschen
sind eigentlich genau so groß aus sich
im pansen menschen relativ zu den
weibchen
trotzdem sind sie ganz nett weil die
weibchen haben versteckte evolution und
die können allianzen bilden und das ist
genau erinnert wie du nicht wann bei
spruch stadt stattfindet und sprung
stattfinden deshalb wissen sie nicht
wann sie quasi wann ihre nachkommen
können auch tatsächlich und dann
brauchen sie also die mitarbeit der
weibchen im gange malt und dann müssen
sie sich zurückhaltend
also dass ein männchen größer und
stärker als ein weibchen also in der
biologie sollten wir kraft es nicht
gleich macht weil hier sehen wir also
andere faktoren die die die macht
beeinflussen nämlich zum beispiel die
allianz bildung der weibchen und diese
verdeckte eisprung wodurch sie eine art
hebelwirkung hat wo er sich benehmen
muss wenn er sich nicht benimmt ist geht
läuft schlecht abziehen also genau diese
situation hatten wir etwas ähnliches
hier auch in unserer eigenen
vergangenheit das klingt natürlich
reichlich pragmatisch jetzt insgesamt
vielleicht so erklärung muss man auch
sagen
ihre argumentation funktion funktioniert
ja auch so dass sie sagen der mensch ist
ein mischwesen zwischen der biologie und
der kultur braucht genau deshalb ist es
ganz wichtig zu verstehen man kann nicht
sondern natur des menschen also zum
beispiel von der natur des mannes dass
er zum beispiel mehr muskelkraft hat
irgendetwas normatives ableiten
genau das ist ja das sowieso meine
praktisch sehen wir bei den
menschenaffen oder bei diesem bonobos
und anderen affenarten auch dass es
schon nicht hinreichen aber bei uns
sehen wird diese variation und überall
zwischen diesen unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftsformen zeigt schon das sei
die kultur die entscheidende
entscheidend ist und die kulturen dann
haben sie das angesprochen irgendwann
beginnen wir haben da bindungen haben
sie pb geschrieben beginnt so etwas wie
die monogamie also nur wo setzen wir das
an weshalb entsteht denn so was wie das
ist offenbar ja auch nicht ganz so
natürlich also monogamie hat mehrere
dimensionen könnte man sagen erstens wie
exklusiv ist sie zweitens wie dauerhafte
und drittens was machen wir damit was
wir an polygonen ändern also ein mann
mit mehreren ehefrauen und das sind
alles elemente die mehr oder weniger
unabhängig voneinander parieren können
und jetzt unsere bis vor kurzem unsere
monogamie auf lebenszeit die exklusiv
ist sein soll
das ist eine könnte man sagen kulturelle
erfindung die sich so und dann komme ich
vielleicht auch ein bisschen auf ihrem
terrain
die sich somit griechischen einflüssen
monogam dann christlichen einflüssen
lebenszeit und auch jesus hat das ja
betont usw keine trennung und dann kommt
man irgendwann auf dieses aber das ist
ein religiös entwickeltes konzept und
sagen das ist ja aber auch so dass doch
im alten im ersten testament zum
beispiel auch zwei ehefrauen bekannt
sind und so polygone lebensformen haben
wir im ersten testament einige
allerdings dann schon in der spätzeit
ich mir also sicher für privilegierte
also in den in den sogenannten erz
eltern erzählungen ist es gang und gäbe
mit den entsprechenden konflikten auch
verbunden aber umgekehrt also poly
andere haben wir nicht so eine frau wäre
ja genau
und dann ist es auch später also in der
königszeit ist ganz klar privileg also
man muss schon reich sein oder eben
könig und dann kann es bis zu 1000
frauen gehen aber es ist dann nicht mehr
die standard form quasi und in der
bildsprache im alten testament schlägt
schon so monogam ist denken durch also
die das verhältnis zwischen der gottheit
und dem
und den gläubigen wird ja auch als bild
beschrieben und halten mit der negative
formulierung als hurerei sobald das volk
sich anderen göttern zuwendet und das
ist dann auch schon monogamen konzipiert
also da gibt ja klar eine und ist dann
männlich überschriebene rolle und eine
weibliche beschriebene rolle und nur
diese zwei und ich meine zeit jesu ich
wüsste jetzt nicht davon vielehe also in
der biblischen zeugnis nicht gewagt salz
rang frage und noch nicht verboten es
wird nicht explizit aber es gibt als
fangfrage also jesus wird dann gefragt
was passiert wenn also bei dieser
sogenannten schwarze also eine frau
heiratet einen der stirb bevor sie
kinder gezeugt haben
dann muss sein ich weiß garnicht bruder
oder sonst wer also ein von wald
männlicher verwandter von ihm diese frau
heiraten sieben mal und so weiter wenn
sie dann auch stirbt mit wem sie dann im
himmel verheiratet aber da geht es
letztlich darum es ist eine frage die
sich über die auferstehung dreht an die
auferstehung hat absurdum zu führen
diese vorstellung und diese für diese
vorstellung oder die die es ebenso wie
soll ich sagen diese vorschrift auch die
frau dann vom von verwandten zu heiraten
das da geht's auch im eigentums
weitergabe ja die also das ist sicher
eine sicherung also jetzt für den
biblischen kontext eine sicherung
natürlich auch in der oralen
gesellschaft also wir haben das auch im
altersheim endlichen buch ruth die
geschichte von der verwitweten frau die
dann letztlich durch list und tücke und
mit einem riesen romantik an den mann
kommt der theben leiblich verwandt ist
mit ihrem verstorbenen mann und das ist
quasi in der familie sie kann vorher
diesen als es geht auch im besitz es
geht um planen
sie kann dieses land also gut ist die
protagonistin kann dieses land nicht als
ihr eigen nennen aber wenn sie dann
diesen anderen mann heiratet also den
nachdem sie wird ist dann kann sie es
sich aneignen dadurch also haben es auch
gebunden an eigentum und verwandtschaft
er auch ja aber nicht als also eben
nicht politisch das möchte ich jetzt
eben doch ein bisschen besser verstehen
weshalb das denn so ist weil sie es
schreiben ja sogar ein buch das es
möglich aber also so ist dass der
weibliche orgasmus auch ein relikt der
promis kritiken als auch weiblich
motiven vergangen
deshalb sind wir denn nicht gemacht für
monogamie oder tendenziell nicht gemacht
also geben sie einen freibrief jeder
gesellschaft machen da müssen wir immer
aktuelle fehler von argumentation
sphären unterscheiden oder aktuell ist
es so dass wir ganz plastisch sind und
es gibt leute die ganz glücklich ein
lebensdauer monogam sind es gibt leute
die das nicht schaffen aber auch wenn
man weder ethnographische schaut es gibt
alles ungefähr bei mensch sogar ein
bisschen poly andré ist nicht so stabil
aber es gibt es auch das ist die eine
sache also man kann mit der biologie
ziemlich viel machen in unserem fall
wenn es um währungssysteme geht wie wir
das nennen
die andere frage ist darf man die
biologie also die unsere
grundausstattung wenn wir die
physiologie anschauen es ist eindeutig
das passt nicht zur lebenslangen
monogamie aber darf man dieses diese
tatsache verwenden als argument zu sagen
deshalb sollten wir die monogamie
verwerfen
das ist die antwort nein das nennt man
den naturalistischen verschlussseite 16
was weiß ich
also man darf es nur machen wenn man
sagt weil
und dann ein argument hinzu knüpft zb tw
bad ist schlecht weil ich dann
argumentiert man von aus einer aus einem
biologischen problem und sagt dass sie
so ein richtiges problem so schwierig
das können wir nur lösen indem wir es
nicht tun
das wäre ein beispiel monogamie ist ja
es ist schwierig aber das andere ist
auch schwierig also es gibt es gibt
keine einfache lösung und auch wenn wir
das historische einfach nur bei den
jägern und sammlern gibt es riesige
variabilität es gibt gesellschaften wo
am ende das wird gemessen natürlich am
ende hat eine frau im durchschnitt zwei
ehemänner gehabt und es gibt wo es 15
gab und weil sie zu kompliziert ist
wollen wir das mal kurz zusammenfassen
bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt was waren denn die drei punkte
die für die weibliche unabhängigkeit
vorhanden waren bis zu diesem zeitpunkt
die danach eben gewissermaßen
ausgeschaltet werden erstmal die
netzwerke also die die verschwinden
sobald die sache patri lokal wird nennen
wir das also die männer zu hause bleiben
die frauen importiert werden genau wie
sie zuvor beschriebenen und das andere
ist natürlich dann die machtverhältnisse
letztendlich ist das alles geht es um
macht wie bei den bonobos wenn wir denn
den weibchen dort die macht wegnehmen
dann werden die männer dominanten ist
ein kräftiger und größe sobald also
diese besitz vererbung eine große rolle
spielt dann wird es vom gehen wir von
patrick lokal patrick lineal das wo die
vererbung stattfindet so patriarchen
denn die männer die mächtigen männern
die wollen unbedingt diese diese linie
instand halten und ihr besitz
weitergeben und dann kommen alle hand
methoden um weibliche sexualität zu
bändigen zu kontrollieren und wenn man
genau wissen muss wer ist mein nachkam
so lud da das ist das allerwichtigste
für ein herz vater oder wie sie auch
heißen in der dieb also sexuelle
autonomie die ökonomische abhängigkeit
oder unabhängigkeit eben und dann zum
schluss noch diese diese netzwerke hat
ist diese dritte erlebt das dritte
element der ökonomischen abhängigkeit
hier sind die frauen ja mehr oder
weniger unabhängig
die sammeln ihre eigene nahrung und
teilen lassen
das ist ein tauschgeschäft das ist eine
ökonomische einheit
wenn hier der mann das land besitzt und
sie ein bisschen da noch selber ein
bisschen so etwas anbauen kann dann
kontrolliert er das total dann hat sie
ihre ökonomische autonomie auch nicht
mehr
hierbei den materie linealen gehört das
land der der weiblichen gruppe hatte hat
er nichts zu sagen also letztendlich ist
es eine machtfrage
und dann geschieht ja sie haben es zuvor
schon ein bisschen angedeutet etwas
furchtbar interessant ist alleine
winzige vorderasiatische religion das
plötzlich ins spiel kommt und eine große
rolle spielt in der in der position der
frau kann sie
das mal kurz nach erzählen naja kurz ist
eine sehr komplexe geschichte natürlich
denn erstmal wären jetzt von von
monotheismus ja das ist ja eine anomalie
hälfte in der religionsgeschichte das
ist einmal passiert dass er sich
durchsetzen konnte nicht also das war
das war ein unglaublicher glücksfall
aber diese diese dieser glaubensrichtung
haben wir jetzt mit allerhand
modifikationen hat sich das bewährt und
hat sich das verbreitet teilweise
natürlich weil es sich wenn wir jetzt
vom vom christentum reden jetzt springe
ich mal in der zeit voraus sich umarmen
und frauen gekümmert hat zb und kranken
das bei anderen religionen war das viel
weniger davon bleiben wir aber noch ein
bisschen dort beim beginn da
interessiert mich natürlich auch die
internet interpretation in der theologie
also diese entstehungszeit und tauchten
auch die rolle der frauen darin also wie
stark diese ganzen religiösen strukturen
eben auch zu unterdrücken der frau
beigetragen haben
also sicher ist also zu beginn meinen
sie dann im ersten testament quasi ich
würde schon sagen die erfolgsgeschichte
und explosion hat wesentlich zum
christentum zu tun also ohne das
christentum wäre es wahrscheinlich
weiterhin die freude asiatische
religionen
wenn es dann noch gäbe also wie oder ist
selbst noch aber im überschaubaren
rahmen
im ersten experiment ist sicher die sie
quasi auch die chinesen ott ist wird er
erzählt und es hat immer so spuren von
politischen hintergrund in den texten
auch als ist ganz klar die die gottheit
ist nicht so wie wir jetzt im song dear
god oder so es ist viel stärker
schillernde gottheit mit mit mehr
anteilen führt auch selbst gespräche mit
sich oder redet im plural mit sich und
das kommt immer wieder vor aber in der
schrift wertung wie wir es haben ist hat
sich quasi diese monotheistische
monotheistische stoßtrupp durchgesetzt
also sicher sind da die propheten starke
also die poeten bücher starke
monotheismus treiber die dann wirklich
versuchen alles andere was vorhanden war
das ist ganz klar das muss man dagegen
sein
also ich muss nicht schreiben das müssen
die erzieherin aus dem tempel
rausgetragen werden wenn sie nicht drin
waren also die vernichtung auch andere
kultgegenstände andere gottheiten
bekämpfung an den rekord halten eben
dann zum teil auch sehr brutal und
mittels geschildert werden sie besser
auf die jagd gegangen als anderen
männern die den kopf einzuschlagen
also da also diese diese monotheismus
bewegung ist im alten testament stark
spürt was ihr in den ersten teilen und
die es geht zu lasten der frauen dass
das wäre eine frage also dass sich eine
verdrängung von die biblische gottheit
ist männlich die alttestamentliche das
ist klar also von dem der eigene name
ist männlich die ganze vokabeln also die
ganzen werben sind männlich geprägt also
es ist ganz klar männlich codiert und
weibliche anteile werden quasi
unterdrückt oder ausgeschieden also als
als abgewehrten sicher beschreiben das
ja auch als herrschaft religion ohne
alltags religion oder ja ja ja das ist
ein unglaublich spannendes phänomen das
zurück zu den jägern und sah man dann
haben wir gemeinsame rituale auch sachen
die nur die frauen macht nun das ist
immer so aber jetzt jeder hat für sein
geltungsbereich quasi dicke die diese
krisen transzendenz also das bedeutet
also keine hierarchische museum nicht
jetzt kommt mit der sesshaftwerdung uns
allmählich werden diese kriege wichtig
werden werden entstehen die ersten
staaten und da sehen wir überall das ist
so eine art gesetzmäßigkeit die größe
götter entstehen was wir heutzutage
religionen nennen würden
und was ist deren bereich das natürlich
krieg und dann wird dann wird es immer
wichtiger das andere bleibt aber
bestehen also man sieht einem größten
strom an einem großen strom und einem
kleinen strom und es kommt der
monotheismus dass wir im buch sagen ist
das jetzt wird das andere nicht nur
tolle nicht mehr toleriert und kann
nicht einfach weitergehen wird verboten
das ist aberglaube
und dann sind insbesondere die frauen
die am das wird ja immer wieder
beschrieben die frauen wollen das nicht
annehmen und in dem moment wird also die
die monogame eine festliche religion
wird intolerant auch monogramm des
platzieren genau gegenüber die frauen
und da hat man ein religiöses ein
theologisches argument und frauen weiter
in die ecke zu drücken
aber es ist schon beides also wenn ich
da kurz sagen ist sicher dieses bei dem
bild mit dem fluss es wird einiges
unterdrückt oder ausgeschieden habe ich
habe vorher noch gesagt und anderes wird
in kultur irrt also es ist sicher so
dass die biblische gottheit auch
weibliche anteile hat oder sich
dezidiert selbst nicht als man versteht
also ich sei es männlich codiert von von
menschen aber es gibt viele anteile oder
bis selbstbeschreibungen oder ebenso
gott bin ich und nicht man steht im buch
josua zum beispiel vor oft falschen
gesetz mit notwendig und nicht menschen
aber es ist quasi auch eine absage an
diese eindeutigkeit aber natürlich ist
also es ist wie bei das ist es eine
unterdrückung und auf die seite schieben
und eine in kultur aktion aber sonst
auch schon eine entwicklung die sich
dort die stattgefunden hat und natürlich
wenn ich als vage see ist klar dass der
der männliche teil der der gewichtigere
ist und genau dass diese entwicklung die
sie jetzt gerade aufgezeichnet haben
möchte ich weiter tragen ich möchte über
das christentum noch sprechen und zwar
genau auch weil sie zum beispiel
schreiben in ihrem buch das christentum
habe die westliche kultur über so lange
zeit bis in den letzten winkel
kontaminiert das finde ich natürlich
eine mutige formulierung dass
kontaminieren
das möchte ich doch noch klären weil das
so an klingt wäre den die welt besser
ohne religion das ist natürlich eine
absurde frage das macht keinen sinn aber
sie ist ja auch nicht denkbar ohne sei
und dass das behauptete natürlich wenn
wir kontaminiert sagen geht es nur um
diese beziehungen zwischen den
geschlechtern
erstens etwas für die weltreligionen
sozusagen ist denn die die welt sich
total verändert und alle mechanismen die
dafür zuständig waren um die moral
aufrecht zu erhalten
weggefallen sind
weil wir in großen anonymen
gesellschaften leben ist die religion
die einzige instanz die sich noch moral
kümmert also man kann das ist bisschen
plakativ sagen die hat uns gerettet
sonst werden wir die er die frühesten
staaten waren man nicht unbedingt ein
ort wo man leben möchte also und sowieso
es ist passiert wie es passiert ist
wir beschreiben ja nur was passiert ist
aber wenn nennen wir über diese was
haben wir gesagt wir haben etwas ganz
ganz böse insgesamt von der
kontaminierung terminierungen genau das
ist also das geht ein bisschen auf
augustinus zurück und eine einrichtung
die das christentum genommen hat der bei
jesus überhaupt noch nicht genau das
wieder was ganz anderes
genau also diese das nennen wir mit
kontamination relativ zu der lehre die
es die jesus gelehrt gut wollen wir das
doch auch noch anschauen weil die weil
das christentum ja ganz stark auch eben
von der griechischen philosophie geprägt
wurde jetzt in bezug auf ihren frauen
begriff oder die entwicklung darauf was
was man von der frau gehalten hat wenn
man an die kirchenväter und so weiter
denkt ja also ich hab mit den kirchen
fans sind sie ja noch mal einen schritt
weiter schon
ich denke auch der quasi um in diesem
sprach bild zu bleiben der sündenfall
der kirche des rüstungs ist die kirche
also quasi die institutionalisierung
dann in dem moment was ich die religion
die ist ja am anfang nicht klar also für
die römer komplett nicht zu
unterscheiden das jüdische sekte also
bei den ersten christenverfolgungen sind
genauso viele jüdische gläubige mit
verfolgt worden die sind ja nicht alle
ins kolosseum geworfen worden sondern im
bergwerk versklavt oder in bordelle
geschickt weil sowohl christen als auch
juden aus römischer sicht die ihre
vorstellung hatten dass kein mensch
verehrt werden soll also der kaiser
nicht verehrt werden soll als gott also
dieser widerstand gegen den kaiser gold
von außen also ein und dieselbe truppe
von innen das sehen wir im neuen
testament sehr große abgrenzung scan für
also die frage an jesus mit der ehe im
himmel und noch andere problematischen
gibt's denn so im ersten jahrhundert im
ersten christlichen jahrhundert so eine
ablösung die dann wirklich auch zur
trennung führt also in bestimmten
theologischen
fragen ist es eine ganz klare trennung
und dann beginnt die
institutionalisierung bei den christen
und die hier ist dann plötzlich wieder
also da bräuchte ich dann vielleicht
auch so ein bild von ihnen
wie also wo da die abzweigung falsch
gelaufen ist weil ich würde schon sagen
dass die ersten also die jesus bewegung
ist das eine aber sicher auch das
christentum corinth oder also die die
christen thema die wir durch die briefe
von paulus kennenlernen
es sind sehr wahrscheinlich egalitär
gewesen und und frauen eine rolle
gespielt und wann kommt dieser grad und
diese verfestigung die sich dann
natürlich im mittelalter noch zu spielen
genau
und da kommt ja noch ein etwas anderes
eine quasi andere ingredienz rein
nämlich dass die sexualität auch
weiblich gepachtet wird also das ist die
sexualität verträumt als ungelegen dass
genau das weiblich also der mann hat
price eine verpflichtung seine
genialität weiterzugeben und alles was
so ein bisschen schmutzig es ist möglich
wenn es mal so bescheuert aber das kommt
uns also darf würde ich schon sagen das
hat uns auch dann die griechische antike
mit eingebrockt das ist also die die
welt in der sich das christentum dann
entfaltet also in der griechisch
römischen welt gibt es eine verschiebung
quasi von relevante ins in richtung rom
die ist nicht ganz frauenfreundlich
nicht vorher
und dieses befreiungs potenzial schaff's
nicht als er mir vorhin gesagt hier ist
nun oder religion überhaupt
monotheistische religionen die sich
kümmern die die missachtete oder
ausgestoßen irgendwie eine rolle geben
die sich eigentlich auch um das eine
gewisse gleichheit kümmern
irgendwo geht es verloren zugunsten von
dem machtclique was wir sagen ist diese
diese griechische philosophie die sich
natürlich an den einfluss nehmen die dir
der rhein integriert worden ist weil man
es natürlich verkaufen müsste außerhalb
vom vom kleinen verwandten gebiet die
ist unglaublich patriarchal geprägten
alle diese zitate von platon aristoteles
und all diese leute das
frauen sind mangelhafte männer das hat
damit zu tun eto'o grafisch dass die
griechen die waren eigentlich hier in
diese phase da so hängen geblieben und
wir uns ganz kleinen gesellschaften
frauenmangel herrscht weil sie branchen
nenner für verteidigung und das ist also
eine ganz das haben sie mitgebracht in
ihrer philosophie und das hat sich dann
ja verknüpft mit dem christlichen
glauben aber wenn ich da den monate ist
geschwind verteidigen darf grieche
schicke sei also nicht verteidigen als
ich richtige gesellschaft also die
vorchristliche ist ja politisch das
leuchtet mir nämlich an der monotheismus
hypothese also nicht an mir leuchtet
viel ein
aber der tolle tourismus ist ja auch
nicht das wahre oder das
gleichberechtigt so genau bisschen 9 okt
ich glaube da sind wir uns einig weil
ich ein gutes weil natürlich ist der
monotheismus den wir kennen ist ja auch
ein politisches system entstanden und
hat dann diese männliche spur bevorzugt
aber genau das wäre dann eben die frage
wie denn das patriarchat in diesen
letzten teilen in politischen
gesellschaften also die nicht dieses
jüdisch christliche erbe haben
entstanden ist sich auch ihr seid
gemacht genau das partie hart gab es ja
schon längst bevor sie überhaupt
judentum kann ja die haben es ja auch
nur importiert von den großen nachbarn
sie wollten sie die waren so beeindruckt
von den großen nachbarn aber es gibt
dann so eine form von oder so ein
konglomerat das entsteht dann durch den
durch den monotheismus und die
verbreitung dieser dieser religion dass
das hat sich so angereichert die jeden
schritt und und dann kommen dann das
wird staatsreligion dann das hat total
andere forderungen und das ist schon
ganz schön spät also es ist ja dann
schon 200 jahren unterwegs und römischen
reich bis start zulegen wird ich denke
schon wahrscheinlich diese
eigentumsbegriff also das ist das denken
aber was passiert wenn ich eigentum habe
und das verteidigen muss weil die ersten
christen sind irgendwelche sklaven und
sklavinnen sehr wenige wohlhabende
menschen die aber dann irgendwie
kommunistisch denken oder so aber nicht
als es dieses eigentums kommt erst
später dazu aber sie zieht
mir jetzt dieses thema mit der
sexualität so ein bisschen weg weil da
interessiert mich noch etwas
es gibt ja diese diese gegenüberstellung
gewissermaßen von der eva und von der
maria und di maria die ja dann letztlich
auch eben mehr oder weniger asexuell
gemacht wenn das sieht der sie hat
jungfräulich empfangen sie etc also sie
es ist keine figur die in die mit 66
qualität in verbindung gebracht wird und
dann möchte ich schon das besser
verstehen weshalb ist das so weshalb
entsteht auch so eine die tony und maria
ist dann eben nicht mehr einfach der
schlechtere mann oder der ja genau
also ist eigentlich die bessere menschen
übernommen
also sie sind also jetzt nach der
heutigen römisch-katholischen kirche
eher leere noch eine stufe quasi höher
die menschheit überhaupt wieso das ist
eine gute frage
es ist sicher also wir haben bei paulus
dieses bild das er in seiner lehre quasi
um die erlösung die er versteht dass sie
in christus gekommen sei um die erlösung
klar zu machen sprich der usl davon
sprechen dass auch erst der mensch
erlösung bedürftig ist und das nimmt er
die vorstellung wie durch also ich sage
es jetzt wahrscheinlich nur in der
luther übersetzung also wie durch einen
der tod so kamen durch einen die
auferstehung also die vorstellung die
der tod der menschheit kommt über adam
und erst spricht adam an namentlich und
jesus oder christus in der sprache von
paulus ist dann wieso das gegengewicht
zu adam ja was da aber theologisch
wichtig ist zu betonen ist adam ist auch
hier der mensch also steht für die
gesamte menschheit und ist nicht
geschlechtlich kommentiert genauso wenig
wie christus in der in dem bild von paul
ist das also quasi die die geschlecht
von jesus ob er jetzt penis hatte oder
nicht eine rolle spielt sondern auch die
vorstellung gott wird mensch der jetzt
an weihnachten in der kirche war hat
vielleicht ein paar mal phrasenhaft
gehört aber trotzdem die vorstellung der
menschwerdung ist nicht die vorstellung
der mann wertung goldes und aber in der
christlichen theologie com wird es dann
quasi geschlechtlich verstanden oder
adam der erste mann der mist gebaut hat
und chris das jetzt als der mann der
diese
lösung bringen auflöst und dann ist das
geschlecht essen braucht man wieso das
zweite paar dazu in der hetero
normativen welt und dann haben wir eva
und maria aber also mario logi ist ja
nicht gerade frauen befreiend also es
ist ja interessant dass wir eine neue
sendung genau muss ich muss ich sie
schon in die schlusskurve mitnehmen
wir sind schon fast am ende der sendung
nämlich und ich möchte da noch etwas
besser verstehen damit wir auch auf so
was lernen können
sie denken ganz anderen zeithorizonten
für uns sind vermutlich schon 2000 jahre
fühlen sich wie eine ewigkeit an
ich frage mich ja wir haben wir haben
doch emotional keinen zugriff auf dieses
auf diese zeit wie können wir trotzdem
kulturell daraus lernen was sie hier
auch ausgearbeitet haben zusammen mit
kai michel
wieso haben wir keinen zugriff also wir
emotional menschen und menschen haben
sich in den letzten paar hunderttausend
ja nicht groß geändert und die letzten
12.000 waren sowieso viel zu wenig um
uns groß genetisch zu ändern wir sind
unglaublich plastisch aber wir haben
unsere präferenzen wie so zum beispiel
regen die frauen sich schon seit langer
zeit auf darüber dass sie unterdrückt
werden in der kirche
das ist das ist alter jäger sammler dna
buchstäblich so etwas das sich in ihnen
wert weil genau das ist das ist
verankert biologisch verankertes
präferenzen denken und also wir sind
aber sehr plastisch wir können uns
ändern die die die beziehung zwischen
subsistenz gesellschaftsform und
glaubenswelt die ist schon längst nicht
mehr zwingend wie die wie die früher war
das können wir jetzt anders denken als
werden wir das wollen
also wir sind wir sind größtenteils frei
um unsere gesellschaft zu gestalten
unser glauben zu gestalten wie wir
wollen deshalb an sie frau streit die
schlussfrage wenn wir jetzt diesen
letzten kleinen zipfel auch vor uns
sehen in diesem einen prozent worin wir
uns befinden sie haben zu beginn auch
gesagt dieser eine prozent ist ihnen ja
auch in den leib ins in leib geschrieben
gewissermaßen auf was dürfen wir dann
hoffen wir hoffen dass man immer auf
alles
also ich würde ihn mitnehmen dass wir in
diesen drei punkten die sie angesprochen
haben
was quasi den frauen verloren gegangen
ist da vor 12.000 jahren dass wir da auf
einem guten weg sind dinge wieder zu
gewinnen also ich leb selber in frauen
netzwerken und wir sind wieder viel
stärker vernetzt die geburtenkontrolle
also dass wir jetzt dieses im also ist
eine entwicklung also es ist eine es ist
glaube ich eine kulturelle
errungenschaft die uns noch sehr weit
bringen kann
den dritten punkt weiß jetzt nicht aber
ich hoffe wir können auch viele hoffen
weil wer unterwegs sind ökonomische
unabhängigkeit da ist es alle autonomie
ja über den eigenen körper entscheidet
ist aber ein schönes schlusswort ich
danke ihnen beiden ganz herzlich für das
schöne gespräch nächste woche geht es
hier um die herausforderungen die sich
paaren aus unterschiedlichen religionen
stellen und jetzt gleich spricht yves
bost mit dem historiker und bestseller
autor philipp blom und zwar über die
zukunftsvision die wir dringend brauchen
wie wir gesehen haben bleiben sie also
dran und bis bald
[Musik]